I don't normally pay to train here why
is that because I'm a pro how do I know
if you're a pro you got some proof at
that point like well if you want to
swing around behind you the big picture
there with dory in the eighth son that's
me hook is that the same biceps was back
in a bit yeah exact same one what do you
look at when you look at it he wouldn't
play what a power system that works no
flex wheeler once said I never saw
Dorian as beatable how does this make
any sense well that's the advantage that
I had over him all the other
bodybuilders idolized Arnold I never did
that so I don't go try to kiss anyone's
ass you were math yeah when I met you
yeah that was extreme first experience
with a girl how old were you oh so you
started early as well so I went into the
semi relaxed pose and on purpose I
properly banged my elbow into him are
you able to a doll have sex when you're
going down to four or five six percent
first thing I ever took was Dyna Bowl
that's kind of like bikini girls is that
only one person's ever been documented
to die for marijuana I mean I don't know
I don't know I don't think it was one
person Wow that's a pretty powerful
thing to say right yeah the brexit thing
people voted to get out so let's get out
with the 18 year old today Dorian Yates
have gone the same route could Dorian
Heights be the shadow now good question
[Music]
today I have a special guest with me
he's one of only 5 bodybuilders ever to
win six or more mr. Olympius he won six
consecutive mister Olympia's they call
him the shadow but by the time today's
interview is over with you're probably
gonna call him the scientist because his
wiring is very different Dorian thanks
for coming down thank you yeah I've been
really looking forward interesting yeah
me too
so so you were in LA I know you went to
mr. Olympia you I was in LA at Gold's
Gym where I think we met many years ago
I was there doing a training camp and
then from there we went to to Vegas
what's the mr. Olympia and I stopped by
in Dallas for a couple of days then I go
to Mexico then I go back to LA and then
I fly back to Europe so are you
constantly traveling or no this is just
a season right it's been pretty busy the
last couple of years with the various
different things that I'm that I'm into
with my business and then the training
and ayahuasca camp down in Costa Rica
now so quite a few things in different
directions so there's been a lot of
traveling three months out of you four
months five months what would you say to
you you never know because it depends
what comes up I probably I travel pretty
much every month for a week or so an
average I would guess and I know you
live in Spain right now but you know
going back to Gold you might read a read
somewhere a story about the fact that
you want to go to gym one time and
apparently all the pros can go work out
there for free but one of the front desk
clerks couldn't recognize you
yeah it was a funny story because as you
know probably back in the day in the 90s
Gold's Gym was owned by a small group of
people and it's very like a family
atmosphere and everybody knew everybody
and I would go there and of course if
you mr. Olympia off your top Pro there
you know you're trained there for free
they're very happy to have you there and
welcome you and all that kind of stuff
but it had been some time since I've
been there and the gym it sold out I
guess to whoever I don't know
cooperation so they've got people
working there that maybe they're not not
familiar with with the body building so
I've gotten there to work out and I'm
like hey I'd like to Train please and
the girls like whatever is $40 or
whatever it was so I don't want to jump
straight in there like hey you know so
I'm like well I don't normally pay to
train here why is that because I'm a pro
you know frozed we don't usually strain
it but ok but how do I know if you're
probably they've got some proof so at
that point like well if you want to
swing around the big picture there with
Dorian Yates on that's me it's so oh ok
let me speak to the manager what was the
reaction was it was the boss come out
like oh my gosh it's Dorian let him in
uh yeah eventually and now I mean now
it's it's great they know me and I go
there and train my people and get a
great reception but I think it was maybe
the the changeover of crew and
everything so yeah that was a little bit
amusing do you do you see a little bit
of that also happen with the brand of
Mistral in piano you went from there to
because that also kind of happened a
little because I'm hearing mixed
feelings on a lot of Alzheimer's I think
what's happened is the mr. Olympia was
you know the pinnacle of bodybuilding
and bodybuilding per se was very popular
in the 80s and the 90s and I would say
bodybuilding as such professional
bodybuilding has declined in its
popularity and a number of people that's
maybe getting involved with it well
there's a whole lot of other classes
that that are around now that didn't
used to be around we just used to have
bodybuilding now you got bodybuilding
mr. Olympia got the 212 class for the
smaller guys now you've got a classic
physique category that's kind of I guess
a push back against the body well then
where a lot of people thought the guys
were getting too
big and you know not looking aesthetic
so they created this class which is you
know if you're a certain height you can
only go up to a certain weight so with
the looking for that kind of classic
physique like Frank Zane or this kind of
then you've got men's physique which is
basically kind of like an advanced
Beachbody really they're looking for a
good upper body and and they wear board
shorts so mm-hmm not much reason legs
like that idea would just make fun of
them because it's like I'm not one of
these people that's in a camp like
bodybuilding is great and the CrossFit
is is terrible or I'm a big believer in
any kind of exercise man like whatever
works for you if you if you find
CrossFit works for you and you like that
do that if you like men's physique and
you don't a train your legs and you just
want to train your upper body it's much
better than sitting on your ass and
doing nothing and watching TV or
whatever so and it kind of exercise man
I don't really do bodybuilding myself
these days because I have some injuries
and I don't feel that it's really what I
need so I do yoga I do Pilates I do
biking I do
even some CrossFit classes sometimes so
so zero you're not hitting weights at
all right now no because it got to a
point where I felt it wasn't really
benefiting me I got a pretty bad
shoulder injury I got a detach
supraspinatus which makes that shoulder
very we're very weak at Ora bicep on
this left side at or a tricep so this
left side is much weaker than than the
right side so is that the same biceps as
back in the day yeah exactly same one so
it's all on the same side all on the
same side where I had these injuries you
know that sure they're all related once
you get one injury that's the stress
moves somewhere else and it's easier to
get another injury so it means if I lift
weights it's kind of an imbalance and
then this shoulder starts hurtin and I
had to make some pains and I found a bit
stiff and I just got it like I got to
work on my mobility and my flexibility
and started looking to yoga and I've
been doing that for about three years
and I loved it I loved going hiking I
love biking I like using my body as a
vehicle and when I was in bodybuilding
I was so immersed in it like a tunnel
vision that I literally did nothing else
I thought about nothing else so now I'm
enjoying being you know
multi-dimensional and doing a lot of
things that I couldn't do then or at
least I told myself I couldn't do them
that's one of the interesting things
about you there is you know when you
peel the onion you're like okay so this
guy's a six times troll Olympia
bodybuilder you know the shadow the lad
spread the Christmas tree and you're
like here's was his upbringing he has
opinions on 911 what's that all about he
has opinions on cycle where's and then
he's a the more you go the more there is
a depth to Dorian Yates and that's what
I think what makes it so interesting for
the audience to want to know more about
you but when you were at mr. Olympia
this last one that you went D how did
you feel about the whole contest did you
I mean I've see Brandon Currie one would
ever think about Brandon Currie as a
physique as a winner well I mean I
respect to all the guys up there they're
all doing their best but if I'm to be
honest and that's that's pretty much
normally what I am I feel the standard
of the mr. Olympia is not what it used
to be
the whole thing's diversified you've got
all these different categories and
classes and everything but the mr.
Olympia the pure bodybuilding itself
you had three guys there that you know I
guess so they were pretty close there
was two guys in what I would say pretty
good shape you know they were in they
were in good shape but they're quite
small guys yeah I'm William Banach okay
circle and a guy from Iran hi bishop ah
yeah I don't couldn't pronounce his name
very good and in good shape but they're
smaller guys they're smaller guys and so
Brandon want it I believe because it's
got more stature it's bigger it looks
much more like a mr. Olympia but he
wasn't in incredible shape so I think it
was probably one of the weaker weaker
mr. Olympius that that we've seen what
do you look at when you look at this I'm
curious like you're where does it go
first and then where does it go good I
look at the average person looks at is
like oh my gosh this answer beats what
do you look at well
he's got very good fullness good
roundness to the muscles and no really
noticeable weak points in that in that
pose but his lack in deep separation and
conditioning that used to be the norm in
the mr. Olympia the conditioning part
yeah the conditioning is what's lacking
this does Kevin Love run as well would
you agree with that were some of the
times he would show up pretty full yeah
it wasn't yeah Kevin had a great
physique but it wasn't consistent in
coming in you know sometimes they did
sometimes it didn't but it wasn't
consistent and coming in that kind of
shape so you see the formless but you
still don't call this to be fully cut up
or condition wouldn't be like in that
shape around about six weeks before the
concepts though I would consider this
six work-in-progress work to do
so this during your era with the guys
competing else Ambati you know all the
guys that were running at that time ray
Cormier all those guys how would today's
body do during that time Brian and Korea
this physique he definitely wouldn't
place in the top six
he wouldn't place $1,000 no why do you
see that is it purely based on the
continues you guys were more girls in it
today I don't know the reasons all all
you know all the factors involved but
you looked at top six in the nineties
add myself Kevin Love rone flex wheeler
Shawn Ray now sell somebody I believe
all those physics are superior to the
winners that we had in the last couple
of years you know I want to ask this
question from you you know because it
this is a typical debate that happens in
every sport right the debate was Jordan
was coming up and the guys prior to him
will say well he would have never lasted
there's seven he's already aliens you
know or you know you would have never
been able to play during Jordan's era
because it was real foul you know the
Jordans rules when he played against the
Pistons they really beat you up right
so a LeBron couldn't have lasted or
Steph Curry would have never existed do
you think a part of that is also that
the old generation has so much pride
behind what they
did that they always like the you know
my father saying you know I was born and
raised in Iran and you were born and
raised in Iran when I was born and
raised in Iran I had to get out of
school at 8 you know eighth grade and I
had to work and do all that and you hear
those stories yeah
do you think there's an element there
was better in my day it was tougher in
my days but do you think there's a
there's an element of that or is it the
fact that there was fewer distractions
where you guys were forced to be so
disciplined because you didn't have a
lot of different ions to make it work
for instance heavyweight boxing I think
we would probably if you're a fan of
boxing you can accept that in the 70s
there was Muhammad Ali
there was Ken Norton there was Joe
Fraser there was George Foreman that was
probably a peak of heavyweight boxing I
think I would agree with you on so for
some reason at that time there was a lot
of you know there's a lot of talent just
coming at that time for various factors
and various reasons and I think that's
probably the case in the 90s and again
there was just bodybuilding there was
not all these other categories there was
not even for instance a guy now maybe
who would have been interested in going
to bodybuilding before maybe now he's
doing Crossfit or maybe is doing MMA or
maybe it's doing men's physique or
classic physique and so there's many
more avenues that an athlete could go
down so if you've got a smaller pool
genetic pool of talent obviously then
it's going to be harder for the for the
standard to be up there so I just think
there was just a lot of really good guys
all at one time in the nineties any one
of those guys on a given day could be
mr. Olympia like 5 or 6 guys today yeah
or even then you know what if if I was
off badly off somebody could have beat
me or you know who plays second to me
Carroll of Rome play second to me shun
rashon ray play second to me flex
wheeler play second I saw some batty
so it was constantly you know going back
and forth depending on who was in shape
at the time I remember Flex Miller once
said he says I never saw Dorian as
beatable but that's flex wheeler like
first wheeler
that time was a human specimen like he
was the LeBron James of bodybuilding you
looked at his physique in there like how
does this make any sense
he himself didn't psychologically think
you're beatable well that's the
advantage that I had over him I had a
little bit more mental tenacity probably
flex had more natural talent than me
because let's say that I did everything
and I put and I achieved 100% and like
my effort and dedication and so I got
100% of my potential fulfilled we'll
never know but let's say for argument
that I did I would say that Flex
probably maybe did 70% because he might
break his diet a little bit would his
hundred have beaten you very possibly
meaning could you have won a single one
if flex was a hundred percent there
we'll never know but I do when we were
competing together like if this guy did
what I do have a real hard time beating
them because I know he made which yeah
if he did what I did if he had my brain
my approach my dedication because he
seemed to develop this phenomenal
physique with not you know an absolute
great deal of effort it came quite easy
to him I think and I think sometimes
when things come easy you don't feel you
don't need to really look and search for
that you know to do that hundred percent
because it's already there all right I
agree there's still one part I was
curious about I mean I used to party in
LA when I got out there eteri and when
you and I met the whole picture of you
and I when we met years and years ago
this is I'm about a hundred pounds
heavier they're almost 80 90 pounds oh
yeah like 220 now - 25 and I was
probably 300 plus there you were mass
yeah when I met you oh I look at
pictures of myself now and holy [ __ ] so
you know you know it's not like a look
at pictures of myself every day but
sometimes picture will come up on a
social media or something like there and
I'm like holy
[ __ ] man and that was yeah that was
extreme so if we put the leaders
bulletin on who won the most in the 90s
its you yeah okay you got six okay but
if we put the leaders bulletin on who
had most fun or would you be ranked
would you be ranked at the bottom
probably probably trade off man trade
off like I just put absolute dedication
into this and fun was like something I
can do later I'm doing this right now
and having too much fun might interfere
and I think that's kind of why one of
the reasons that I stayed where I was in
England although weather was you know
some pressure for me to move to
California I was working for the wieder
company for the magazines Joe Weider
they would like me to be out there so
it'd have more access to me and you know
do more photos do more stuff and then
you know like you say you're in LA full
of hot chicks full of parties nice
weather I was scared to relax man
because if I relaxed a little bit and
enjoyed it
maybe I just lose it you know so I want
to stay isolated stay in UK stay in
Birmingham like where my gym was yeah
and just keep my head down and go to the
gym and train and come home and eat and
sleep and just that whole routine which
is like a training camp which people
might do for two or three months before
a contest I took that approach you
around you know and at that point or
you're married I'm assuming you're
married yeah I was in every time you
compete professionally you were married
I wasn't married the whole time but I
was with my partner and then here we got
married I think we got married after I
got second in the Olympic because we had
a bit of money like you know we had
forward to get married you know and I
thought it was time like hey you know I
like I got to this place and this
woman's been with me and supporting me
and like yeah we should get married now
did you see that as a formula amongst
winners like the one the guys who won at
the top consistently were married with
fewer distractions and the guys that
were second third fourth place well
Brent the guy that was an inspiration
for me was Lee Haney because he was mr.
Olympia before me mr. Olympia pretty
much when I started he was mr. Olympia
from 84
and Lee Haney was a married man and he
was a family man and I think they had a
cured as well pretty around the same
time as me so he was somebody I could
look at like well this is a family guy I
can relate to him and she was a lot of
the other guys were single so I wasn't
that you know early on so Lee Haney was
an inspiration for me how to like you
know balance your family and the sport
and so on and for sure I think it gives
you it gives you that stability if
you're single and you've got all the
distractions parties girls and you know
that pulls you out of your training mode
I mean I remember I go to Century Club
in LA I don't know if you've ever been
to a Century Club you go to Century Club
in LA and all these guys would be there
yeah all the time so you would see
you're like this guy's partying pretty
hard I know the name I just saw about a
competition
go to Vegas late all this after-hours
I'm like right these guys are training
you know and party in a hardcore
is what they were doing but uh nobody
hearing anything about you you were
quiet on your own Island doing your
thing you were just coming in I don't
want anyone to hear anything about me
I didn't want anyone to know too much
about me is that cause your personality
it's part of my personality like my
privacy and it worked psychologically as
well because of becoming an enigma that
they couldn't get a handle on me I mean
they don't see me they see each other in
the gym every day so Oh summer so yeah I
see him as having a down day two days
you know an argument this girlfriend or
did you see this guy doesn't look so
good and you know blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah so everyone got to like
handle on each other but Darian knows
because I was out of it you know I was
out of the picture they don't know
nothing just like this creating this
monster in their mind that's just in
this basement and it's throwing weights
around and it's you know creating this
mystique where they you know that they
accepted they couldn't beat me and if
they're telling themselves they can't
beat me then for sure they can't be I
mean this is great in their own reality
with the thought it's now possible if
you say he is unbeatable
then that will be so then it's game over
already if you say that how much of your
your formula for winning was your wiring
on how you were born like this is how a
Benson cell
as a kid I watch everybody I was a guy
that would send home wouldn't say llama
now watch what he's doing what he's
doing what he's doing and how much of it
was your benefit of a you know from when
your father passed I think you were
living in a city called Hurley I don't
know if the new yeah a little uh it's
kind of a little farm we had some horses
and chickens and dogs and stuff all
community a small community you moved to
Birmingham yeah but I mean looking back
I did some unusual things when I was a
kid like no but nobody told me that was
unusual like nobody really said anything
to me one time we had a charity run at
school and it was like around the 400
meter track they wanted to buy new mini
bus for the school or something they
have money and winner for a bus so that
the one who raised money so we got
sponsored so you go around and knocking
on doors and like will you sponsor me so
much a lap you know run around the track
so yeah five pounds ten pence whatever
it was and I remember there was another
guy who was a runner was from a family
of boxers they're all lightweight boxers
so he's real wiry and he told me was a
great runner and I told him um I'm
better running the new I probably wasn't
but I told him I was so we had this
thing where we're going to see you as a
better runner when we run around the
track so we're running around you know
kids do five laps six laps that they're
dropping out gets to 10 15 laps just me
and this other good guy right and I'm
like I can't give up because I'm not
going to give up I got to keep going
right keep going keep going 20 laps or
something like that the guy drops out
feeling well but then something happens
to me like I didn't feel anything and I
just kept running kept running like
Forrest Gump running running running I
went round the track 45 times everyone
had gone home except for the teacher
that had a witness this thing and signed
the paper that you've actually done this
and she said Doran I he got a stop now I
got to go home like 11 so then I went
round to all the people that promised to
pay me five pence a lap and like go and
I got 45 what is that real I'm like yeah
a teacher signed it there but I don't
know
didn't even occur to me that it was
unusual at the time and another thing we
got in England is called bonfire night
November the 5th celebrating burning a
guy on a bonfire because he tried to
blow up the houses of parliament but
when you're a kid you don't realize
that's kind of a sick thing to do but
it's good guy yeah like you build a
dummy like a man yeah because the guy
who was called Guy Fawkes and he tried
to blow up the British Parliament so
they caught him and that was his
punishment right so every year on
November the 5th is like a big thing you
have a party you know cook food and you
have the big bonfire and it put the guy
on top and your fireworks and everything
so I wanted to build a big bonfire and I
had this little pony it's like 10 11
years old I had it an axe and my horse
and I went and I chop trees down tied a
rug to the trees and dragged the trees
on with my horse and build this big
bonfire all on my own and I look back
now I was like man that was that was
crazy you were doing that and but it
just seemed normal and nobody was like
no my parents weren't saying like wow
that's too well done you did something
correct it's just like normal so you
weren't so I had this ignition
I had this focus yeah I had this focus
was working for recognition it was no it
wasn't I just wanted to do it did you
have a relationship with your like
because the one part I'm curious about
is I know my upbringing you know I was
born and raised in around 10 years and I
lived at a refugee camp two years in
Germany the whole war with Iran Iraq
there was an element of me wanting to
prove and win against the odds they
didn't believe I could do it et cetera
et cetera what was your relationship
like with your mom and what was your
relationship like with your dad well I
was probably closer to my mom because my
mum was there on a daily basis my dad
was in and out he wasn't really at home
then what she was kind of just to his
own thing so maybe I was I don't know
maybe I was trying to get my dad's
attention I'm not really sure but I just
always had that like tenacity if I'm
doing something I just do it and I don't
think well that must be hard work or I
don't really think about I'll just do it
but after my father passed away I'm sure
that was a driving factor to succeed and
I spoke to quite a few people that you
know had some trauma or loss while they
were earlier on that gives them the
drive maybe you're looking for that
recognition may be looking for that love
or feedback that you didn't get earlier
on I'm not quite sure but we all got
these things in our lives traumas
incidents and it's like whether you're
going to use it or it's going to affect
you in a positive or a negative way so I
took that and I used that fuel whatever
it was and maybe it was the anger there
as well I'm sure there was a lot of
anger there that my father died and I
didn't feel like anyone really helped me
through that or I didn't really process
it we're going to talk about it you know
so probably I used all that that energy
could go in a negative way if you know
people get into alcohol and drugs and an
addiction and behaviors because of those
things you have a lot of friends that
did they win a complete different run
like this yeah I mean I went as a
teenager I was like off the rails a
little bit for a couple of years and I
got sent to a detention center which is
they say a youth jail facility when I
was in there as I realized like [ __ ]
this I don't want to be I'm not I don't
belong here at all you're eighteen
eighteen or your 80 not well but you
know I'm like I could see first of all I
was smarter than the people in there and
then we were in the gym went to the gym
and I was like I was killing everybody
in the gym and had the best physique and
like wow this is something that can be
good at I did a little bit of weights
before I did karate and I had this
Foundation and so yeah I saw the people
around me and some of the people I grew
up with they're they're not here you
know some drug overdoses some suicides
user friends yeah and some people still
in in jail or in out of jail so that's
the what I grew up around I had no
family backing really no education not
much prospects so I found this thing
that was just first of all I was
naturally inclined to it and secondly I
found it fascinating like the process of
how you can change your body with the
training and the diet and what's the
best way to do it what's the best way to
eat and I got to figure all this stuff
out myself that was fascinating but were
you in high school if I was in high
school with you were 14 15 16
pretty shy but still in like I would be
in with the group that would be I don't
know most popular or like you know a
little bit tough guys that that people
cup so I'll be in that group but the
same time was always been a bit of a
loner so I'd be in the group but I'd be
out of the group
so always kind of like do my own thing
and even then when we're like 1718 and
we used to go to concerts and things
like this I'll be the one that organized
everything I'll make sure we got the
tickets and I'll check the transport and
so I was always kind of like a little
general how old were you had your first
girlfriend first experience with a girl
how old we really curious like also you
started early as well of me and my mom
she we had a few horses right so she
used to horse riding lessons so who does
horse riding young girls so I got the
girls coming to the place Oh brilliant
so so your shyness didn't bleed into you
knowing that you like girls ain't gonna
go up to me you know you know you know I
got interested in girls pretty young
pretty young okay and in Birmingham
based on the study I did a little bit on
Birmingham I mean Bourbon Kim's got
reputation with gangs would back in the
days with Birmingham I think it's called
Birmingham boys or the peaky blinders or
somebody's you read about yeah that kind
of serious now called peaky blinders
so that's based on like nineteen
twenties but I mean I think it's put
Birmingham on the map a little bit like
people watch that series and the like
Birmingham ah they've never heard of it
before maybe they heard of Birmingham
Alabama you know I asked that because I
went to UK I went to London and I spent
a day with Katie Hopkins I don't know if
you know Katie Hopkins use to your
personality like a Nigel Faraj type of
personality and then with a guy named
Sean Atwood and then David Courtney on a
tight corner Dave Courtney I think he
used to do security for the Kray twins I
used to be involved in a big security
company in in London and you know he's
known as the celebrity gangster
celebrity gangster yes the rights books
and everything like that very
entertaining which is pretty interesting
combination celebrity gangster yes so
like oxymoron oh so it's an oxymoron
yes
you know now it can't be a gangster
because this is very public so I'm sure
we got all the connections and
everything already but there's a today
did they ever reach out to you I know
cuz I think we create Wednesday they
died in a late 90s or 2001 you one was a
kind of like hey we're proud that you
coming from UK was there any of that or
no they never reached out I actually
spoke to Reggie Kray on the phone one
time which was a bit surreal because I
read all the books and everything when I
was a kid right wondering yeah they're
famous I think the book was called
profession of violence that a red man
was at school you know they're like
mythical characters in England and
somebody came to the gym a bodybuilder
came to a gym and I said we're
organizing this contest and the profit
from the contest is going to go to boys
boxing clubs in the East End of London
and the craze of you know involved in
this and so it's for charity for the
Krays charity that opening boxing clubs
are something for kids will you come
along and do something and do guest
posing or something so I said sure man
if it's you know was it going for a good
cause and then this guy at a gym pick up
the phone and say I want to speak to
door I know it's like hey was it it's
Reggie Kray no son it's Reggie Kray okay
give it to me and I'll go chat with them
and I was like thanking me for doing
that and if there's anything you need
son anything at all you know you let me
know and so it was a little surreal
moment anything you need
yeah they're killing they can go many
different ways how old were you at the
time when that phone call was made from
I was I think I was mr. Olympia so I
would have been like thirty awesome okay
you already that's why I don't want to
miss a guess bozcaada
you know I'd bring people in I was
thinking because you were mr. Britain
I'm thinking long after that hey come on
in Night of Champions
I'm mr. Britain it's not such a big deal
I mean I remember I won the British
championship 1986 yeah so I'm British
champion British champion got the trophy
go home I got this council apartment
which council and England is like it's
from a city and I was like projects or
something so I got this council flat I
got no carpet on the floor
and I have a proper bed I just got a
mattress I don't having a car because
every penny that I earned from my work
and it's just going for food training
catching the bus back and forward
whatever I don't have any money for a
car so here I am back in my same
apartment he with my trophy
I just been to 3,000 people screaming
going crazy I got my trophy and British
champion but still in the same situation
so it took some time to to get out of
that someone backed me in opening the
gym opening temple gym because I was
British champion so that was my first
leg up I started you know then to make
an income from foreigner bodybuilding is
that 87 would yours temple the age of
seven we opened yeah and 88 I won the
British championship again and the whole
the overall thing and that's when I was
eligible to turn pro and go compete
which really at that point is in a body
was more international now at that point
it was really like an American sport
there was not that many successful
people outside of the states got it so
at this point Arnold has come here he
has won his from Austria it's still not
an international sport it's still mainly
us wieder is running the whole thing you
come out here was your first mr. ole
with Haney when Haney was was their
first one where you stood on that was
first mr. Olympia how was that
experience for you standing next to a
knee well there's another funny story I
was telling my friend the other day so
it comes to mind so Lee Haney is mr.
Olympia when I'm when I'm starting out
right so this is the guy that I'm
looking his mr. Olympia plus is a family
man and you know he's big I saw him
guest pose in England its inspiration
big guy so I'm a fan basically but now
I'm gonna go compete against him so I
realized I can't be a fan anymore man I
got to get a little bit ruthless here
yeah it's changed my mind
right maybe I can beat this guy maybe
I'm better than him why not
sure it doesn't train as hard as you so
you know this process is going on until
I'm like got into a mine space we're all
right I'm gonna go and I'm gonna try and
beat this guy no I won't but I'm gonna
give him our best shot and I'm going
there with this positive attitude I'm
not gonna know there's a fanboy so I
already was in that frame of mind and
you know when I compete and very focused
almost would like quiet aggressiveness
so as a guy in New York telling my story
which I found out later was total
[ __ ] right well he told me the story
and is the only guy I knew at this point
I don't know many people in American
bodybuilding community so there's this
gym owner in New York that was my
contact right and he knew everybody know
all the people in it I didn't know
anybody so it's telling me stuff I'm
believing him she was like you got to
watch out for Haney on stage he's a
bully
I say what do you mean oh you know you
try to intimidate you
he'll bang into you a little bit he
might tread on your toe or something and
I just want to like bully you and on the
stage where my what he's not doing that
[ __ ] to me now I'm getting off sites off
and everything so I've got to mr.
Olympia my first mr. Olympia right I'm
psyched I'm on a stage and there's a
call-out and it's just me and Haney
which is unusual to guys right so it's
obvious this is a showdown right for
first in a second so I started to walk
out and Lee's give me the you know
friendly smile
I'll give him a stone face then I've
walked out and you know you're coming
and going this kind of relaxed semi
relaxed pose so I went into the semi
relaxed pose a nun purpose I properly
banged my elbow into him and he must
have but what the hell is this crazy on
video like I don't know if you get video
over the fridge oh he might get that way
yeah you might get that yeah so I banged
into him and I did it a couple of times
to learn to let him know you know and
then in the pose down Lee Haena does
this pose where he brings out his arms
like this and I was behind and I know
who kind of got me out of corner of his
eye he clipped me with his with his
knuckle I think it was like okay I have
some back you know and then I was yours
and yours afterwards I sat down with him
and got a chance you know we don't see
each other that often I was
and I got a chance to sit down and talk
one-on-one and likely I need to talk to
about something it's like what's that
well I kind of need to apologize for
something it's a what so did you
remember and you know that Olympia and I
came and I'm banging and listen it's
like yeah I thought you wanted to fight
me or something that he said this yeah
remember yeah I'm like yeah well this
happened and you know as a [ __ ]
story and I'm young and I'm psyched up
and I'm sorry because this is just a
gentleman is the I knew he was a very
much gentleman so the story was totally
booked Oh [ __ ] but I took it on
board two-six I loved it I loved the
fact that the guy from New York told you
this was he like your agent or manager
or no do you want it to be but it's just
a guy's for [ __ ] not good how common was
that because you know when you hear what
Arnold psychologically destroys Lou
Ferrigno and he says hey you look like
you're six weeks out or four week says
yeah like give me some more time I don't
know you know there's some of that there
obviously but some of that was for the
movie for the drama for the camera is
there any other thing that's about
saying like when you get a pump is like
calming its [ __ ] nothing like coming
my own time under that squat bar is
horrible this you know you want to sound
it to the public that's a good one how
much of a bed did you have to prevent
while you're getting prepared for
competition was a like babe I can't have
sex for nah it wasn't anything like that
it was there was no like like boxing or
something where they're trying to retain
their energy or whatever there was no
real reason to do that but it happened
anyway from just complete exhaustion
like I was completely exhausted like the
last four or five weeks before mr.
Olympia and sex was just like something
that was not my body was just on
survival mode man it's not interested in
trying to procreate and not at all No
thank you not no energy I go to the gym
I put everything and then I'll come home
I'll be like literally like this because
your honor you know it's the only sport
where you're eating less you're eating
less calories are giving your body less
fuel and you're doing more training and
high
training and you know he's trying to get
contradictory goal of maximum muscle
mass and minimum body fat is totally
contradictory and they're trying to
balance that and it's exhausting are you
able to at all have sex when you're
going down to four or five six percent
three percent body fat I mean is there
any it was no there's no inclination
there's no drive there's no interest I
mean I literally like get that tired
it's even tiring just to talk sometimes
is any want to talk yeah I remember one
of the pictures where you you know you
said at the lowest level was what three
and a half percent or maybe measure it
in his skin fall calipers that I was
using and that would get down to like
three point five percent about four or
five weeks out and I know I got leaner
after that but it wasn't it registering
were you out here what would you say you
are here I don't know but this is about
four weeks out from mr. Olympia so this
if you look at the condition in here
this would probably be superior to most
of the guys on this that's ready this
looks competition see this is four weeks
this is ready this is ready but I had to
go extra on top of that I always kind of
like I was known as a masked monster one
of the first mass monster yes because of
the muscle mass I heard but I always
competed below what I potentially could
do because I want it to be super
shredded I just didn't want to be big
and okay sort of always competed below
below my potential size because I want
it to be absolutely shredded I want it
to be you know dry and shredded as as
well as big not just big so I probably
always overdid things I never under did
things always overdid things shown this
this is for four to six weeks out this
is not but you in today's world that
variance curry today you'd be ready to
be on stage with them competing today
yeah there's more separation there if
you look I got more separation already
and that's four weeks out yeah was it
almost annoying to be around you like
were you were you getting annoyed by
people like I could be but I kept myself
away from them because I didn't want to
like but I'm talking like family like
you know cuz sometimes being married you
know I have a laugh with my son about
this because just one incident where I
lost a little bit
I used to take my son and my nephew's to
Kentucky Fried Chicken or McDonald's on
a weekend and I just had a black coffee
and Jenin bother me right it didn't
bother me
what my son had this like ice popsicle
lollipop whatever you call it here in
the states you know so he got this thing
and he's got a bit of chocolate on his
got these little sprinkles on and then
it's got collars and so we're watching
TV together
and he's like and he's like just
savoring this thing for so long it's
just like it just driving me crazy in
there and I start so what say please
take that in the kitchen and eat it man
it's taking a kitchen eat it please yeah
at one point I just lost it a little bit
so we were off about that now you know
well it's just one incident so the most
part you're pretty you know I was like
look I'm choosing to do this yeah I'm
choosing to do this I'm choosing to put
my body through this so it's not fair
for me to take out any kind of like
frustrations or you know moods out on
other people so I pretty isolate myself
when I was at home and most of the time
I was cool just you know just keep it to
myself what is it like being married to
a type a competitor you're not in the 1%
category you're not into one percent of
one percent category you into one
percent of one percent of one percent of
one percent 7 billion people living in
the world there's only one mr. Olympia
there's a lot of people that are trying
to be bodybuilders what is it to be
married to that guy who is like a
scientist like you that's paying
attention to detail saying this is four
weeks out and I still want to go lower
how was that part was it was it
difficult was it annoying was it like in
over my wife for in yet for your wife
being around you we read as well I'm
asking because this is well the thing is
we met around about the time that I just
started training and not planned at all
we had a child so Louis together so
Debbie who was my wife she's seen the
whole thing right and and at first she
didn't understand it nobody understood
it
what the hell are you doing and why are
you eating like a robot
we tune off in three hours and doing
this and what's this all about right
what fortunately I was successful very
quickly after a year and a half training
I went to compete on a novice contest
absolutely like I didn't know at the
time I just thought this is where I need
to be but now I look back it's like
there's no comparison or when the
contest so easily then I had like judges
and officials or there was one guy Ron
Davis who was he used to judge at the
mr. Olympia and he was the head of the
Federation in England he was there and
it was Darian nice to where are you from
I'm like from Birmingham what are you
doing in the novice class well I'm a
novice is my first contest so well you
should be in the heavyweight class no no
no I'm not I'm not good enough for that
yet you started laughing like he's not
gonna know how kid you're the best
heavyweight we've seen in this country
I'm like know about this guy and this
guy surely they're better than me
no so we want you to come and compete in
the world games like next week on the
British team as a heavyweight and this
is the world championship this next week
yeah the world championship and I didn't
want to go because I knew I wasn't ready
to win that yet and I'm what's the point
of going if I'm not ready to win that
was my whole mentality or not well they
kind of persuaded me to go on the team
so I went and I got 7th place there and
13 guys and these were like the best
amateurs in the world the whole was
gonna turn throw 23 23 23 so I started
training properly when I was 21 23 you
know the the massive recognition at the
the first show I got my first magazine
article I'm going to the the World
Championship and give 7th place there
after training year and a half 13 so
people around me could recognize all
this is not a waste of time now this guy
is you know not a client dream is like
Debbie then understood what I was doing
and got behind me fully and she always
was behind me and had great faith in
what I was doing and when I went to my
first pro show which was in knife
champions in New York
and I got second place there which was
$7,000 that was my pro earning seven
thousand dollars and then Vince McMahon
from WWE he started a bodybuilding
Federation and Tom Platts who was my
hero
one of my heroes was like reppin you
know he was the guy that was putting
this thing together
and they contacted me because they liked
my look that it was a very rugged and
you know I had a different look because
they were looking for like interesting
looks like they got with the wrestlers
and different personalities different
looks and I had this look that was mean
and they flew me out there to
Connecticut where their headquarters is
and give me a whole tour around and had
a meeting with Vince McMahon's wife and
they offered me something like 170 grand
a year to go and be with that Federation
it's money at that time I had nothing I
had nothing crazy so I gone home to my
wife and I said look they offered me
this if I take this we can get a house
we can do this we can do that when we're
living in is still in a council place
man I'm Ron young turned pro but I'm
still living in the ghetto right not
much money I got $7,000 and much to her
credit she said I'm out of this so I got
nothing to say about this this is
entirely your decision to make so you
need to you know you need to make the
decision why did she see that what's
what's her reasoning for giving it to
you because if she had I said do it
let's take the money I probably would
have maybe thought this to it I mean
she'd been behind me all this time the
family needs something stand back you
know I you know the family's been behind
me and now I got this and maybe I should
do it for the family but she said no no
you got to figure this out honest and
then I was like you know what I really
believe in myself and the Olympia is the
Olympia and I got a feeling I got a bad
feeling about this Wrestling Federation
because the one thing that I was adamant
about when I went there I was like I'm
not a performer I'm not you know if this
is gonna be like the wrestling where
it's like you're a character and that
winners already kind of chosen I'm not
in for that I'm and I want to compete
I'm an athlete I'm a sports person I
want to compete I want to compete
against the best and it's got to be a
competition
they assured me it would be like that
what I had my doubts and then you know
mr. Olympia is everybody builders dream
mm-hmm so I'd have to give up on that
dream to go with the Wrestling
Federation so I made a tough decision
and I said I'm gonna turn down this
money because I got faith in myself and
I will get that money and more if I
stick to this path and I win mr. Olympia
so I had to call Tom Platts and say no
to tom platt which this is somebody you
admire it's like such a fan of tom platt
I remember the first time I met him and
I must have had like because it happens
to me and I say to people don't worry
man
it happened to me when I was a kid
because they come to me and they're like
I got a thousand questions for you but I
don't know what to say now I say listen
don't worry man happened to me but you
know mmm so I know how you feel yeah I
was a fan I met Tom Platts I had a
thousand questions and I was like Hello
so I had to call Tom Platts and say Tom
I thought this through and I'm gonna
have to decline the offer I think I can
be mr. Olympia and I'm gonna keep on
this path in Tom's never been mr.
Olympia you know he had two quads but he
never won this role you know he didn't
he got second or third I think in 81
which was controversial because Franco
Columbu won that with still a very very
badly damaged leg from the injury got in
World's Strongest Man so that was
probably one of the most controversial
mr. Lemp is along with the 1980 that
Arnold one in Australia the one that
when he got on stage you know a lot of
experts says he didn't look like he was
ready to win the whole thing
no I don't know I mean look at pictures
and it's not a lot of video around
because think Arnold brought it all up
so you can't watch it anymore but you
can see some pictures and Arnold
definitely was not at its best but still
Arnold is impressive on stage he's a big
man is it's tall and his wide and make
the other guys look a little bit small
so I don't know if you should have won
or not and I can't really say I wasn't
there do you think guy like that could
win today because right now it's what
you said to 12 closer to 12 right and he
was 225 I think it's maybe
35 hours birthday that's six two and a
half that's considered to be but he was
still head and shoulders the best at the
time yeah with what was available as far
as training knowledge and let's be
honest pharmaceuticals and so on that
were used so if you took Arnold and you
put him in two days or you know the 90s
or whatever and with a bit of training
knowledge we have and more
pharmaceuticals that we were using and
so on he would have been bigger so yeah
that's a good point I mean he's great
genetically the Arnold's like specimen
you've got these pecs and biceps still
and there's like 70 something years old
whether his legs and back would be up to
today standard I don't know it was the
chest that he yeah you look like you
know I mean still no one's got pecs like
that
yeah there's just phenomenal pecs and
bicep is is like still common man
could've gone to Vegas and Venus
stripper yeah but that's what were your
relationship with Arnold how was how is
there with the two of you guys because
you don't really have much of a
relationship
I've never haven't really spoken to
Arnold that much have you guys ever had
a sit-down ever had never had a sit-down
never had a sit-down and I've never all
the other bodybuilders idolized Arnold
and they seek him out because maybe they
can do something for them or whatever I
never did that I'm my own man so I don't
go to try to kiss anyone's ass but you
you had a reaction like that to plants
how come you didn't have that to him
because because Arnold was not really
from my era it was from the seventies
and I you know I grew up and started
bodybuilding 80s so I was looking at the
current geyser which was men sir and
plants and maybe also something about
Harlan's personality that didn't really
jive with me was Arthur Jones the
founder of Nautilus I think at one point
we don't have on a million year was he
an Arnold fan I don't really know I know
Arnold went out there to train at a
facility out there in Florida and
I think Arthur Jonah said he didn't he
didn't like it
that's why yes - haha because I wonder
because Arthur Jones's personality seems
like your personality a little bit I
don't know if it is about could be I
could be wrong not so much about
personality but I read all his books and
it just resonated with me like this is
logic this makes sense right first of
all it makes sense secondly let me do it
in practice and see what happens so it
could make great sense but if I do and
it doesn't work then what's it worth
it's worth nothing right so I'd it and I
experimented and I have kept logs I've
got every single workout that I ever did
from 1983 to 1997 written down come on
every single worker 83 283 297 I wrote
down every single workout and there's
notes underneath how much waste did I
use what exercise how many reps did I do
and then every month I would do it a
check I would set goals for the next
month so now I can benchpress 300 pounds
for eight reps next month they want to
be 310 so I would set goals that were
realistic yeah but every month if they
all add up a day in the year you've got
a big thing right so it was all very
calculated and planned and and
strategize like a general like when I
was a kid when we used to go to concerts
I've been the one that you know get the
train tickets in there and the the
constant tickets and organize everything
all the guys would just turn up and go
along like well I'll be the one doing
the planning and strategizing so that's
what I was doing so I could analyze what
I was doing okay I'm training three days
a week and this is happening I'm
training four days a week analyze
analyze what happens I noticed that if I
did increase the volume and the
frequency of the workouts my progress
kind of came to a stop and when I did a
little bit less very intense really hard
training but less shorter workouts less
frequently I start growing again and I
tell people often that they're stuck
they're stuck in a gym first thing you
need to do take a week off take a week
off come back to a more abbreviated
program and
come talk to me Darian I took a week off
guess what happened I came back I was
stronger oh no [ __ ] man cuz your buddy
was just like needed the break your over
trained you need a rest come back
restored rebuild you're stronger stop
overtraining how long were you in the
gym like was you know these missing some
maximum album will you Bacardi or now
really I used to do cardio like a couple
of times a week and offseason just to
keep some cardio conditioning like 30
minutes two times that nothing crazy
nothing crazy but getting ready for a
contest I do a lot more but it was low
intensity cardio so it was just
basically calorie burning so I'd do 45
minutes in the morning on a stationary
bike moderate heart rate like 115 120
and in the evening I do 45 minutes power
walking fast walking so I had a dog I
had a boxer yeah his role mm-hmm beefed
up chunky boxer he used to walk with me
for and also live with you lift weights
but he'd get ripped go up and down
together you know Dorian I've heard a
lot of different stories about Joe
Weider
you know if you read the book Total
Recall and Arnold talks about when he
first came to the States and he thought
headquarters of wieder was a massive
misuk wait a minute I thought this was a
massive building he says well you know
this is the impression that were
something one day we're going to be
right what stories do you have with Joe
Weider yourself well it was when I came
on the scene in 90s that they had a big
office in Woodland Hills with I don't
know how many employees like 50 60
employees in the magazine place they're
covered with American Western art and
everything was it was impressive
so I was just recalling one of my visits
to the office when I went there because
if I was in town Joe always bite me to
the office or would go for lunch
together he always liked to be spend
some time with that with the champions
that he says the champions are all my
friends are all my family so one day I
went and I went into his office and
chatting away and for some reason he
starts showing me pictures of him when
it was young when he used to train and
volley build
and I'm thinking well it's not very
impressive I know he didn't have a great
physique so but anyway I'm like yeah
whatever I'm not saying too much then it
pulls out one picture it's like a most
Moscow or something like this and it was
thick and round and I'm like wow Joe
that picture I never seen that one
before you look great there so we're
chatting away and afterwards I leave the
office and a bump into pizza McGough
who's the editor reflects and muscle and
fitness and his from UK and we've been
friends for yours so is that how did it
go with Joe I said you know it's okay
man you know chatting away and wow man
he showed me this picture that I never
seen before when it was younger and it's
actually really big and thick and round
and so Peter says to me was it this
picture like this like this pose okay
exactly that's the one man it's like
that's not Joe's body that's the body of
Clancy Ross who was a whatever mr.
America or something in the 50s and
Joe's like superimposed his head on top
of the body which I found fascinating
because I probably be looking at Joe and
thinking wow look at this guy with his
huge company in all his millions and
everything that's amazing but it's
almost I felt like he would have given
higher up just to be mr. and M feel like
he really wanted to be a bodybuilder and
he had a almost like a childlike passion
for bodybuilding so yeah people say it
was a cold businessman he was here as a
businessman so if you don't have to pay
you nothing he wouldn't pay you right he
was a businessman I want to make maximum
return but he had a genuine love for
bodybuilding it wasn't there just to
exploit it he didn't he did love the
sport you felt that when I felt that
yeah like almost like a child like I he
used to come to photoshoots and
supervise a photoshoot with me and the
guys in his late seventies and I say to
him Joe what are you doing here so what
do you mean Harlem doing here
you don't have to do this while you're
here man if I was you I'll be like in
the Bahamas obviously on a beach or
something I'll be doing something and
it's like though this is my passion this
is what I love doing and if I don't do
this what I'm gonna do
curl up and die so this is what you got
to respect that yeah but some anything
how he put the picture just for you was
it a way for you to have the level of
respect that Wow at one point he all sad
if is I don't think he made that picture
for me I think it was already good pizza
magrav already knew about it so
obviously had already shown it to other
people and that kind of worked it out
that you're not gonna say anything to
Joe though is the bus right yeah it just
showed me that like often in life people
have something mm-hmm but the grass is
always greener on the other side you
always want something else you want what
you can't have
yeah what was your favorite magazine to
read by the way muscle Mack I remember
flex I'm a muscular development I
remember Muscle & Fitness I remember
Muscle media mm was it for which one was
the one you you like the most
well I had such a collection of
magazines which got destroyed I had a
flood in my basement one time and just
destroyed all my magazines I had the
biggest collection because I collected
every one every one everything that was
published every magazine every book when
I started lifting to when I finish and
then I had people gave me stuff all my
brother and older brothers got these old
magazines so one guy gave me all these
little Iron Man if you remember these
very small Iron Man magazines as really
old school news it was very independent
and almost like the opposite to wieder
where wieder took bodybuilding and
created this illusion as you say Arnold
went there and expected this big
building and it was it was very small
the same thing he created this illusion
of bodybuilding where you're on the
beach with a protein shake and the hot
girls and there's like as if it's a
lifestyle that we're all doing here
how are you doing that you've got no
money there's no problems no money in
bodybuilding so it's like an illusion
he's making bodybuilding like cool and
trendy and fashionable and desirable
where Ironman was a bit more like
old-school and more basic and practical
advice and
because of the training advice you've
gotten from Joe Weider was Arnold's 20
sets six times a week and so on that
doesn't that didn't work so one was the
logic one was the dream yeah ability to
whatever I liked oh I like the older
Iron Man's just for the practical
information in there and muscle builder
I was as it was called later became
Muscle & Fitness there was no flex
magazine it was muscle builder was the
first wieder magazine I saw and they had
Robbie Robinson on the front who I just
actually we had breakfast together I was
out in LA in his mid 70s and still in
great shape the peak on his biceps never
made sense to me right be kind of it
just like muscle on top of muscles like
a heel on top of it and he knows that's
when you would look at very impressive
variants you know that's genetic is not
some kind of training you can do if you
had it's just the shape you're you're
born with so yeah it was fascinating to
see somebody that was so successful but
you could still see they would love to
be something else but you know it's
something you can't buy you can't buy
genetics as its gonna make you into a
great bodybuilder
any any experience you had with Bill
Phillips wouldn't my muscle media $2
never never but I'm familiar with the
magazine here's to read it used to enjoy
it I thought it was a very good magnet I
thought like you would've liked because
it was actually I had some stuff that
was pretty impressive yeah I read all
those magazines I met the probably eyes
on a magazine published between 83 and
87 that I haven't read I got a friend of
mine is about to my age in Birmingham it
runs a gym there so we've known each
other since I started competing and has
this thing where he'll take a picture of
physique without the head and send it to
me and see if I can get it and you know
not guys from the Olympia that would be
obvious like guys from mr. America or
something like that and I don't think
he's ever got me like I didn't know it
was real I read so many magazines like I
know everybody so you're also historian
of the gamers yeah historian and
analyzer and historian of physics and
training methods and I think that could
be helpful do i I did you push by the
way what
well you know those whole thing about
pushing with what was your max on Ben
Shahn biceps on squats what would you
wanna know man cuz I never did a max
like as in a single yeah I can tell you
what I did for working sets were three
like eight reps eight reps bench like
500 okay eight reps been sick I bent
over rows was like 450 or something I
was using them they're squats I stopped
doing like when I was an amateur of stop
doing heavy like barbell squats because
I had an injury I use mainly machines so
you know I don't even know how much is
on the leg press but we had a leg press
and then you know you got the bars
coming out on the side mm-hmm so we had
an extension bar so we had one make
somebody made it where it fits in to the
hole then it extends out again so you
can put more plates on and then a bar on
the top to put more plates on there so I
don't know leg press probably like 1500
deadlifts I never went heavy on
deadlifts I only did the kind of like
you know 450 500 max at the end of a
back workout so I was strong I was
shoulder pressing 160 dumbbells for
Fidel's 120 pound dumbbell flyes the way
I look at it the more weight you lift in
strict form for a number of reps
correlates to how big the muscles are if
you want to get bigger you got to get
stronger so that's why I always kept the
records and everything so I had my
targets to achieve for you you're super
competitive yeah it's very obviously
very very competitive right you know I
talked to Kobe and I asked Kobe versus
Jordan right there's a couple different
differences between those two guys
Kobe wanted to compete purely basketball
yeah he could care less about ping-pong
about this about that about that about
all this other stuffs Jordan wanted to
beat you in everything right he's kind
of like I'm gonna do this I'm going to
do that yeah what was your level of
competition in one topic that intrigued
you the most and you were not interested
in everything else is that kind of I was
an absolute tunnel vision and I didn't
have any ambitions to use that as a
springboard to something else in itself
was this goal where Arnold was using
bodybuilding to get into movies and
and into politics and all this kind of
stuff which I have zero interest in zero
so what was your end game like you're
like I'm gonna win six mr. Olympius like
in one day well you know hopefully
change the trajectory of my life give me
some security and I did think I wanted
to get into the gym business that that's
what I wanted to do did or didn't I did
I thought I did good I realized so I
didn't and it's not a great business to
get into so my main business now is
sports nutrition I've d-y nutrition so
we're doing sports nutrition
bodybuilding nutrition and we're now
looking to go to get some products for
wellness and so on because if I'm
interested in something I will devour
the material if I'm not I just can't
learn so I need to be interested I'm
very interested in now in wellness and
how nutrition and supplementation can
affect health and longevity and also the
the mental aspect of how you affect your
health with your thoughts and so on so
we're going to bring products more out
along that line looking at see we do
have been a big supporter of cannabis
for decades before it was even you know
on the radar of being fashionable and
accepted almost now when did you become
a supporter of it well I've been in a
kind of occasional smoker of cannabis
since I was a teenager but I just didn't
consider it a recreational thing like
having a beer or wine or something to
relax and I thought it's probably
nothing great for you but at some point
after I retired I started looking for
information and finding information
about cannabis and I found out that Rick
Simpson that was cured his own cancer
and curing a lot of people multiple
people with cancer with the cannabis
extract and then I found a guy called
Robert mallow made dr. Mallin made who's
a leading researcher on at the UCLA game
or I think I'm not sure what university
is from but his speciality is field that
he specializes in is free radicals and
how free radicals affect cells and aging
and everything like this and this guy is
like
huge advocate of cannabis and that's his
field as speciality and is like there's
nothing that works like cannabis for you
know for killing the free radicals and
protecting themselves do you read only
pro arguments or you also read anti
arguments valid anti arguments earth if
there's one that that makes any sense
has anything ever made sense to you if
there's any ever been an argument you're
like you know did like some of the ones
I say it's not a good idea for somebody
that's very young like fifteen sixteen
seventeen to be consuming any kind of
like mind-altering substance because
your brain is still developing so there
may be some vulnerability there at an
early age if you're using cannabis or
any other kind of not even alcohol and
other substances of that age I wouldn't
probably recommend it there may be some
risk I think if you are susceptible and
family to having schizophrenia stuff
well I run an headline a camp in Costa
Rica I asked a camp and we have a
disclaimer if you have any history of
schizophrenia or any kind of mental
illness in your family you're not
allowed to do it because you're
vulnerable you know it could be just
something that tips the balance so there
may be some argument there I'm not sure
if if it does influence that or not but
some people to say that that it might in
young people only so there may be a
negative there look I've come to realize
nothing in life is black or white
nothing is all good nothing is all bad
so you might have a substance like
cannabis it's very beneficial but in
some circumstances it might be a
negative you know if you're gonna
overuse it or use it habitually you're
not gonna get a lot of things done so
even though I'm a kind of issues I'm a
disciplined user I'm old enough to be
disciplined I'm not a kid right so I'll
use that when it's appropriate I never
smoked before if I'm doing business or
if I'm doing appearances or if I'm going
to work in the gym I never do that I do
it when I'm when I'm out in a nature or
it's time for me to relax yeah i know ii
you you also say that
while you take a two-week break just
yeah I take I take a month break a
two-month break which I time when I do
my Alaska camps because anyway you have
to go on a specific diet and clean out
to do the camp you're not allowed to
drink free it's not recommended pre
during and afterwards so it probably
like three or four weeks and reading at
a time and it's good to exercise
discipline with anything did you support
while you were competing were you was it
part of your routine or now it's not a
regular thing but it was an occasional
thing just like having a glass of wine
was in a cage under half every night
maybe on the weekend I'll have a glass
of wine and at what point did you start
experiencing with steroids and
additional drugs before my first
competition because I knew the guys I
was competing against we're using
steroids so I'm like this is you know
this is this is part of the game right
and if you're going to compete without
steroids you're going to be at a great
disadvantage not impossible maybe if
you're genetically much more gifted than
the other guys well actually my first
competition wasn't with the Federation
it was a local competition
mr. Birmingham and I won that while I
was natural and the guy that placed
second and third I you know I knew them
so I knew they were using steroids and I
was still able to beat them and I dieted
for like a week that's right yeah and
natural but when I went to the
Federation and I know it was a different
standard then I I started about 12 weeks
before a competition would you start off
or was the first example I was so so
little to what people use now but still
it was dramatic because the first time I
ever touched anything
first thing I ever took was dinoball
okay
20 milligrams a day of dinoball I took
that for six weeks and then I switched
over to promote one prima ball and shot
a week and a little bit of a Hannah bar
like 15 milligrams or something that's
kind of like bikini girls use that now
and the Primo was like pre competition
stuff yeah it was not too really good no
that was when I was you know I did a
little bit to build up and then then I
came down with a diet got it and that
was in pretty good shape I diet for like
seven weeks or something when did you
really because even when you went
against Lee Haney when you get out when
you got on stage and you look at you you
look good yeah you look like this
I can win but you took it to a whole
different level so at what point that
you kind of a taker came up and
experienced with the next level I was
just using steroids up to that point so
the next level was growth hormone which
was very expensive and not that
available but now I got second in the
mr. Olympia so now I got income and I
got contacts and I decided let's let's
try a growth hormone I'm sure that my
competitors are already using it or some
of them so I started with that and that
like enabled me to go to another level
over the next few years what was the
what was the reaction you would get was
there different things when you took
this you felt like this you know had the
whole thing with temper acne react you
know was there anything you're like but
when I use this I got to be careful
because my fuse get shorter when I use
as I feel like I can take over the world
when I yes yeah I had that aggression
but most of the time it didn't spill out
because I used to I used most of it in
the gym and I wasn't in a lot of
situations where it could be triggered
like a lot of guys at the gym they used
to work security and the nightclubs and
so on I did that very earlier on but
when I started competing and then I got
the gym I didn't need to do that and I
didn't want to do it anymore so I was
not going you know I was not going out
to bars or nightclubs where somebody
might piss you off or you know so I kept
myself kind of bit isolated and I did
feel aggression but it was like a
controlled aggression that I could use
for the workouts as far as side effects
water retention acne some of my blood I
did get blood checks and some of them
were out of the normal range
it was my doctor told me and you're not
dying yet but you know it's not a
healthy thing to care two key words it's
you know dying yeah you know don't you
know it's not it's not perfect but your
body's under stress well this is your
profession and you're earning good money
so my advice to you is do this and get
in and get out and don't do it for too
long how long did you stay at the peak
of experiencing with steroids basically
mr. Olympia reign which was it was six
years my I think my intake
while I was an amateur was it was a
really kind of moderate well then I got
second in the mr. Olympia what if I can
go mmm another level you know let's say
you know and now it's it's worth any
potential risks maybe what is the level
of usage n versus today for somebody
that's committed today today is much
more is it twice as much fifty three
times as much or three three times as
much so if you're competing in today's
times with what's accessible today how
would you have been the same size or was
there a limit to your size or would you
have to be I think you know there's a
point where it's beneficial up to a you
know bell curve and then it's it's not
and I think possibly one of the reasons
where the guys are not getting into
shape now or having trouble getting into
shape is because they're using a lot of
stuff and it's hard they don't show the
details and the separation that they
have the volume or they don't have the
details in the separation and I'm not
sure exactly why that is because I'm not
really a fait with everything that
everyone's like using now I do help some
people now to train them and everyone
that comes to train with me is surprised
because they think Dorian Yates he's the
guy you know the the growth hormone guy
the the steroid their insulin they're
going is so [ __ ] big he must have
been he wasn't ten times more than
everybody else
you know we're all using pretty much the
same thing the thing that was different
when my it was my approach in my
training that's the difference were you
guys all talking about what you're using
or a little bit yeah okay so everybody's
pretty open about that so and most of
the guys were using I use a growth form
on a day when we're competing we're all
like talking on you know that was pretty
much an average it seemed so I'm you
know pretty much know now people use
people that don't even compete using a
lot of steroids well back then it was
mainly mostly people that competed it'll
be a few guys in the gym or take a
little stuff because that you know
whatever they wanted to look big but the
majority of people are competing and a
lot of people wanted to compete then now
you go to the gym and look how many
people want to compete in the gym though
there will be nobody or one guy maybe
then it's like all the guys at my gym
they all wanted to compete that was the
thing everyone wanted to do it there was
like the peak of interest which is now a
declined and
what would the 18-year old today Doron
Yeates have gone the same route with all
these different options Wow
good question probably but could dorian
yates be the shadow now in this day and
age where the industry is like very much
on social media yeah so it would be hard
because people use social media now to
promote their selves to promote their
business to make an income in fact some
of the biggest earners in a sport then
never compete mm-hmm they're just on
social media and then they get millions
of followers and from that they
capitalize on that and they make an
income and they think pocket I don't
even need to go through all that [ __ ]
and compete I'm not you know I got a
business anyway in my day you needed to
compete and you need to be successful in
a high level in order to get yourself in
a magazine which gives you exposure and
gives a publicity and then you'll get
income was anybody even making money
during your era I mean I heard Sean Ray
was good with money right for your first
place so you're obviously making money
because you're getting the sponsorships
but even after second third place I mean
the money is like 50 grand 40 grand 20
grand how are people making money do
they all have full-time careers no they
I think maybe top six or top ten in the
mr. Olympia can make a career making
income solely from bodybuilding because
you haven't you just got the prize money
you've got sponsorship deals which if
you're a top place I would probably be
more than your prize money on an annual
basis and then you've got appearance
fees guest posing seminars etc so people
make an income from them so it's not
just from the prize money but still
compared to other sports is I mean it's
chump change right yeah I think right
now we were talking about a $400,000
right now first X is what they paid
during your talents one guy that's one
guy yeah and then it goes down goes down
rapidly real quick yeah it goes down
from a $400,000 to I don't know what
that I know during your time it was
between 100 $250,000 on you so you know
when you you you know how woman can see
another woman and they can say oh she
got a nose job
and we were like oblivious to it we're
like all the time yeah she's on Botox
yeah she got her would he call that
tummy tuck well I have no idea yeah but
you watch NBA players or you I don't
know if you watch NBA you watch a
certain sport can you look and say that
guy's on something when you see somebody
can you pretty much say somebody's on
using something or not I can't say 100%
okay but I could have my suspicions
especially if they change quite quickly
I've seen a lot of fighters that I
alright you know he's just put on like
10 15 pounds of muscle in the last year
that's no way you're doing that without
you isn't something there's money
there's money here man people you know
we're talking about high level sports
highly highly driven people they're not
going to miss anything that's going to
help them there so if they can do it and
they can get away with it and mostly
they're doing it mostly they're doing
yeah what do you look for do you look
for a job do you look for vascularity do
you look for sudden size increases yeah
if somebody makes a big increase over
you then that's that's a telltale sign
because some people can be muscular
naturally muscular anyway some people
have done well in bodybuilding being
natural may run in Coleman I believe who
was eight times mr. Olympia after me I
believe he got as high as a world
championship maybe even competing and
mr. Olympia by being it with being
natural Wow I believe so if you look at
his physique when he's in the mr.
Olympia in 1992 when I won the first one
compared to when he was winning
it's huge and I could believe that
there's some people that just very
genetically gift I want to see men go a
little bit further
he placed 13th or something like that
yeah he was he was in the top ten he
kind of he had their skinny big body was
different then Paul de let's physique
because you know Paul delenn had a
different kind of a body there yeah
although I'm just comparing both because
they had a certain length to themselves
but for you when you when you think
about body but then who are your
Mount Rushmore who do you put up there's
a greatest bodybuilders of all time how
it put yourself out there who would you
sear the top five in your eyes um sir
Joe Olivia yeah so Joe Olivia they're
just people that stand out to be like
wow this is mr. Allen at the time I mean
it's like something from another planet
at that time the late sixties right
amazing sir jewel have you had their
fingers poles you know do oh yeah very
few people can do that but their arms
overhead maybe I can look at he could do
that in you couldn't believe it so Joe
Oliver Arnold Lee Haney Ronnie Coleman
and myself and I taught me not to put
myself in there but maybe your top five
it's like mr. Olympia should be a
standout it's like not a little bit
better than the other guys stand out and
it should be a guy of some stature and I
think a little guy I find it hard to to
see a little guy as being mr. Olympia
you talk about that a lot why is that
what's when you say little guy what is
little guy to you you're talking like
five eight and under is that kind of too
little guy like yeah I mean mr. Olympia
you're talking about the best
bodybuilder in the world and even if you
showed to a member of the general public
a small guy levy like really you know I
expect the guy to be like the impressive
and huge stature so those are the guys
that stand out to me to be like they
were really head and shoulders above the
competition at a time I don't say that I
was head and shoulders above the
competition but you know six years in a
row but my competition was very intense
I mean Arnold it didn't really have I
think some mr. Olympia is only Arnold
and other mr. limp is that some nobody
that can come close to him Lee Haney as
well one may eight mr. Olympius but he
didn't really have intense competition
he knew if he came in pretty good shape
it was his it was you know it was head
and shoulders above everybody and Ronnie
was very hard to be in as well
Jay Cutler did beat him in the end but
Ronnie was in a decline from injuries at
that point would you do my surgeon
embrace physique to me
he's surgery a lot like a panther or
something I mean real quality to his
muscles interesting physique yeah and
interesting training I used to train for
hours
LaBrie literally for hours was he afraid
his French friend from from some France
Guadalupe or some French Caribbean
island it was from France yeah so he got
his initial sighs I guess training heavy
and then years later he would just train
for hours and that's maintaining his
size and keeping him very earlier I
think it takes some kind of stimulant as
well when his training adjusted to train
for hours and it just be always super
lean I thought he had a you know I would
put him more like you Frank st. a very
in the very small waist little joint yes
maybe some similarity to flex wheeler in
that order d what's coming up but Sergio
liver is I mean Arthur Jones was the one
that really bought genetics and you know
as a factor wasn't really talked about
before like you know by Arnold's chess
routine and get a chest like Arnold's
like no you can't you know Arnold is
Arnold so Arthur Jones pointed that out
is like you know your potential of a
muscle to grow is limited by the length
of the muscle belly because it can never
be wider than it is long as it would
have function so if you've got long
muscle bellies you have the potential to
build more muscle mass and Sergio Olivia
had uniformly long muscle bellies on
like everywhere in his body it's
probably the most genetically gifted who
what would you see what his older ever
he was the most genetically powered
buying so yeah Wow that's a pretty
powerful thing to say right yeah I mean
rock Ronnie was very gifted but I would
say sure Joe has probably had the best
genetics and look what the guy looked
like in the late sixties with what they
had available and let me ask you this
Phil Phil he speaks very highly of you
and Phil he he sees you as more also
scientist because he's also guy that
went to school got his degree he got a
degree in accounting and then decides to
go into body but them because he was a
genetic freak as well fair what he was
doing in basketball
I'm just curious your opinion
last year when he went against he right
and he gets a rodent and you know you
look the picture here when the two went
against each other there was a lot of
controversy that's probably not the best
picture because abs abs maybe fellas not
fully flexing his abs did were you at
mr. Olympia I wasn't there at all or now
really I did follow it and there was a
lot of criticism against Phil Heath
previous to this for his stomach about
his stomach yes Bally being protruding
mm-hmm being distended so the judges
were hearing this an Arnold made a big
issue as well at his contest about why
the guys got big bellies now so there
was like a lash back almost against guys
having distended bellies so you can see
on this picture that still filled is
having some trouble mm-hmm with his
abdominal area I think had a hernia as
well he did so on this pose I'd say he's
losing on this pose just because it is
an absinthe I posed and Sean's showing
more separation well that's just one
pose there's seven compulsory poses that
that are scored so we'd have to look at
all seven them - did you follow that
over now really when it was taking place
not really but I'm the opinion that Sean
was kind of lucky because maybe Phil was
not at his best and also he's being you
know they were really analyzing his
abdominal area to see how it was but you
know Phil is clearly a better
bodybuilder it doesn't have weak points
sean has still his arms are quite weak
his back is a bit weak sometimes I
wonder you know in boxing you know one
of the reasons I'm not a boxing fan i
watch a good fight just watch a good
high but it's not like what it used to
be when you used to it was different for
me when I watched before then I do today
but you know sometimes boxing this whole
political thing with boxing the judges
oh I scored a scorecard this again
triple G versus Canelo whatever you know
this I don't know about at least in
boxing and come on out you cannot be
come on now there's no
that's what I'm saying too bad right
like Ruiz knocked out the heavyweight I
don't know
and it's no debates black I'm like what
yeah so you know you look at this and
you're seeing a guy like Phil who is
maybe trying to go get us eight or nine
right you know you dig the gift he's
going after it and he's good for the
brand maybe he's not the most light
figure because he doesn't want to do
what everybody tells him to do and some
of the guys don't like him
how much is politics involved in in mr.
Olympia well I don't think it's possible
to fix the contest because you'd have to
set everyone in the room and you know
pre planet but people are influenced by
what's going on and what's being said
and so on so I'm sure on this contest
because there's so much backlash and
criticism about Phil's distended stomach
over the past two years I'm sure it was
an issue that everybody was looking at
right you know so it came more into
focus and maybe that's what led him down
and maybe that's why I lost the contest
but again I'd have to see all the poses
to have a really strong opinion I'd
really I'd really be curious about your
your thoughts on it because you know I
asked around and a lot of people say
Phil should have won it but they just
kind of wanted to go a different
direction to you know have maybe it was
kind of sending a message that this we
don't want this thing and him like yeah
it looks bad it could be a you know a
general feeling of that not I don't
think it's possible to fix the contest
I'll be you know if the conscience was
fixed it would have come out by now
somebody would have said something you
know you you think you think any other
brand can't compete with mr. Olympia
brand very difficult I hear a rumor that
there's another contest next year that I
hear is well known yes I don't wanna say
too much but what do you think about
that we don't have to mention a name
because we ya know but what do you think
I think it's great okay it's great more
competitions good in anything so for
instance when Vince McMahon came along
with the wbf or whatever it was the
model and Federation and offered all
these contracts out to the
and give some big contracts you know 200
250 grand a year to guys we die had to
step up their game up to that point Joe
Weider was not really handing out big
contracts well now he's got competition
and they can handing out contracts so we
don't then had to step up we there was a
businessman if you get you did do
something for free they get you to do it
for free and that's what used to happen
in the magazines all those guys didn't
get paid back in the day they'd get
maybe some ad space where they could
sell their booklets or something like
there and then you can make money so
that's what Joey is to give them nothing
true that's the form of payment from job
yeah they give nothing man as little as
possible right there's a businessman so
you really love that you really think
somebody can compete with the brand with
mr. Olympia mr. Olympia I don't think
they would want to I think they'd want
to work in conjunction I don't think
that can compete against like a normal
class again but if somebody came along
and started their own Federation and put
up huge money yeah they could well why
would somebody put up huge money unless
they're gonna get a return the question
is is you know the challenge has always
been are people gonna pay to watch it
you know I'm sure the national
television and is is big studios gonna
be okay with knowing that everybody's on
g8 steroids is this a family tell you
know that's always been a bit of a I
don't think bodybuilding is like I never
I was realistic I'm a thought in Bali
one's gonna be mainstream like football
or baseball or soccer or something like
that it's too specialized and again we
got that you know you got the
controversy about the drugs not that
bodybuilding is the only sport that is
involved with that a lot of sports you
know if cycling of course any many
sports but everyone is obvious right
because you look so different and you
know got this guy huge muscles with
veins everywhere I mean it looks it
looks extraordinary to the average
person so immediately they think oh
that's drugs where you see a guy riding
up mountains for hours that you don't
think that because it looked like a
regular guy skinny yeah Armstrong yeah
well everybody else is doing the OPD
yeah and he's one of many and he's
p-ting in that marketplace who are you
close to any mr. Olympia guys you got
really close to where you have a
friendship with I'm friends probably
best friend I got the guys that I used
to compete against he came towards the
end is Chris Cormier he come to England
- I put a kind of a challenge out to him
because Chris is just like the biggest
party guy and you don't mind me saying
that
he's the biggest party guy in
bodybuilding everyone knows that right
so Chris is partying as multiple
girlfriends all this chaos going on and
still he's doing very well so I said hey
man you should come over to England
train with me because you need to be
like a boxer like Tyson going to the
Catskills or something he like just put
yourself in isolation away from all this
nonsense man I mean it's always there if
you want it right he's always a party or
a girl or what I saw is there a man but
switch it off put yourself into this
100% come to England I'll train you get
you a plumber by the gym and you could
win mr. Olympia he don't listen to me
for about five or six years then he came
out and they had some injuries and I'm
like Chris that's not happening now man
it's too late yesterday I read somewhere
of 16 years ago the guy was inclined
pressing six plates
yeah you're as strong as a brawler a
ridiculous amount of weight was pushing
he came to train me you can still see
the on YouTube because you come to train
legs with me and he lost his lunch
outside the gym well you have a
reputation for that I'm yeah because I
push people to where they haven't been
before and he said himself it's like I'm
like been in this game for so long I've
trained with all the top people or top
trainers I said I didn't know [ __ ] did
you spend a lot of time with Mike in
Rain Man sir or no not a lot of time I
mean Mike was one of my heroes when I
started physique I liked his physique
was like powerful strong rugged but it
was more about the a intellect and the
the question in mind which I had and the
the training methods of trainer systems
which basically came from Arthur Jones
and he just tweaked a little bit and I
took that and tweaked it a little bit
and someone introduced me to Mike when I
went out to Venice and we were going to
do a clothing brand together so you know
we're getting close but Mike and Ray
were like they had an interesting
relationship they were always always
fighting so it did the whole clothing
plan we had an earth thing fell apart
because those guys were always clashing
and falling out with each other and so
on so the whole the clothing thing
didn't work out and Mike was most of the
time very rational and stable but
sometimes he wasn't he had problems with
alcohol and feta means and stuff like
that so I think he'll be back and forth
with that so that's why we you know
train with him a few times and kind of
backed off after a bit when I saw that
situation yeah I think he died in or one
and and his brother died like a couple
weeks there's some rap story yeah and I
don't Mike passed away and Ray was
shortly afterwards so I don't know how
that happened yeah I think Ray was not
was not super healthy anyway he was not
he'll know he already had a heart attack
mild heart attack and had some kidney
problems I think it was on medication
for that so I don't know what happened
maybe he lost his brother and he decided
he didn't want to live and I really
don't know the guy you provide you
couldn't live without pretty interesting
when you think about yeah let me ask you
you know you know how you're coming up
and a lot of times I think it's 1957
when they ban marijuana I think that's
the year when marijuana can a third is
is it 3030 says the guy who yeah he was
worried about linking it to Caucasians
you know being without most of it was
sponsored by alcohol companies and then
you got the paper companies that didn't
want to HAMP to be used they want to you
know here's the trees and the forces
yeah there's a lot of forces that were
that were working against it but you
know today fast forward till today only
one person's
ever been documented to die for
marijuana right I mean I don't know I
don't know I don't think there's one
post 60 days ago there's that one person
yeah I had these guys that were debating
donors and I know this is because these
guys were debating there was one person
that a parent
I know vaping right now is five but i
thought everyone has one person and all
these years has been documented and it's
five million for alcohol it's a very big
number for alcohol right but go to
steroids you know you go to stairs and
you think about the names these are just
names
I remember you got is it monster Andres
Monson sooon hamid vanna's Issa
Sonya Schmidt ahsoka P Anna of Salvati
you know you got somebody named names
you're looking at from you knowing what
you know how much of it is linked to the
actual usage of the drugs and how much
of it is maybe they did things on the
side that also caused that
well here's the thing once once you you
know because doctors used to say first
of all steroids are very dangerous
secondly they don't do anything for your
athletic performance so well you're
lying about the one thing because we
know athletes know it's going to pre
increase in performance solutely so
you've probably lying about the other
thing as well so i think as a matter of
quantity and duration and individual
genetics like some people can smoke
cigarettes to let 80 90 years old and
they're fine somebody else smoke
cigarettes and have a heart attack in
their forties so individuals and also
once you you kind of lose your
inhibitions about taking chemicals and
drugs because there's a steroid and then
there's the anti estrogen and then
there's a something else and then then
guys take you know maybe a painkiller
and anti-inflammatory it just lose that
fear and then I think some of the people
that have had fatalities in bodybuilding
um steroids may be a factor but I think
there's other things involved as well
Mohammed Ben Aziza
died from diuretic use directives are
very dangerous people use them to lose
water to get you know try and get in
shape better what you lose electrolytes
as well you lose sodium potassium you
can you know you know you can stop your
heart if you're a sodium potassium is
it's too imbalanced and that's what
happened Ben Aziz or literally the whole
body was cramping
and the hearts of muscle and his his
heart cramped might Maserati
obviously using steroids but Mike used
to eat five pounds of beef a day as well
so that was probably more effective than
the steroids or the combine of the two
five pounds of beef oh yeah yeah I
really need that kind of meeting are it
mainly chicken and egg whites a little
bit of beef now and then but now it you
know we're starting to learn now that
red meat and you know even super high
protein all the time it's probably not
that healthy for you so you got a
combination of factors here all all
going on and then some people using
recreational drugs as well on top of all
this is like you know it's abuse you
could say and if anything outside a
medical use could be abuse and there
were maybe we're all abusing them but my
approach was to use what I needed to use
to get the benefit from it and where is
that where is enough from where is too
much so I pretty much figured that out
so there was some stress on my body but
it's like the way I look at it is like
okay so maybe it's like smoking so I
smoked for 10 years and then I stopped
dude you know I make you know I'm making
their comparison between taking steroids
and smoking so 10 years of steroid use
and then stopping and then following a
different lifestyle
that's what I'm doing now so I'll
probably kind of maybe repairing some of
the damage if body's got a very good
ability to repair itself if you're given
it the right environment in the right
things so factors and what one point
when I'm in the army I wish I had the
picture to show it to you my barracks
the entire wall was pictures of all of
you every one of you yeah during that
time yourself Cormier
you know even Aaron Baker out on a few
more about the all these guys on my wall
I'm talking I didn't use a single inch
some of it was women I had to have a
woman as well because a sergeant angel
teves was one there was another I think
Monica Brian Monica Brian had all these
pictures on the wall right and for me
I'm gonna be mr. Olympia I made that
decision at 16 years old I think I want
to make a run at this right and then I
got out and I started spending time with
these guys and I actually went and
looked at analytics at 18 years old 19
as I started looking I'm like you know
what you're 6 4 ok your calves are
skinnier than your forearms are ok you
you're your legs okay these days guys
don't seem to have an income I agree
with that
maybe it works today but we were pretty
stacked it came down to that so I looked
at the whole thing then logically I just
said you know I don't know if I'm the
right height to win today because you
saw Kovacs 400 pounds jean-pierre Fuchs
yeah you know he had this physique and
there was some of these guys in that
community the taller guys right you can
see any guys at that time runner for a
total guy to have very balanced
proportions normally a taller guys got
his legs are too long or something the
promotions are better often and it
doesn't look as impressive would post
Arnold who's won that's six you know
that's got nobody
so what you're 511 I believe 511 I found
myself Lee Haney and Ronnie Coleman all
about the same height so you you think
the prime height is 510 511 maybe shy of
6 it looks like that yeah it looks like
that you've got the stature you know
you're not very small he got the stature
you got to carry a lot of size and and
fill out that frame and look very
impressive whether taller guys somehow
they lack something Lou Ferrigno came
back in 92 and competed I think is six
six or something like that
he looked very good to look better than
he did back in the 70s but today I
couldn't it couldn't get in the top ten
I think it was like 13 for something
yeah it's it's a game for 511 based on
based on what data tells me is this are
you big math guy or you big data guy are
you a big numbers guy I'm pretty good
with numbers because I spent many years
throwing numbers around in my head so I
would sit down and if there was a food
in front of me it was just a habit
I would analyze how much calories I
think of there how much carbs I'm
surprised just like a process going on
and I did it for years after I stopped
competing I didn't want to do it
it was annoying me that
I would do that I'll just shut up man
just eat your dinner you don't need to
know that anymore but it's still
clicking away you know it was a habit so
I'm always playing around with numbers
so I'm pretty good at working on
percentages and numbers and stuff did
you ever say like you know I think I can
go be a hedge fund manager or goobie is
that never like that I've never pulled
you into going to because it's not
interesting for me yeah there's not
passion so yeah
even mine it doesn't really interest me
that much as long as I got enough to do
what I need to do it's like it's not a
really huge driving factor for me would
you consider yourself a masochist I know
this is a strange question let me be
simplify I may be somebody that enjoys
pain like you know the way you explain
pain and suffering is like you know
maybe this guy like you would say I used
to sit there was uncomfortable and I
would sit down but I'm like man I'm so
glad I am because that just means I gave
everything yeah did you enjoy pain like
it was it's I'm not a guy that wants to
be tied to a wall and whipped in a
dungeon or something like that and
there's not pain in itself
I don't enjoy I enjoy the ability to
master the pain and to be above it and
to be able to go through it with my
determination because your impulses are
telling you to stop it's hurting why
would you carry on just stop man but
know there's a goal at the end that I
want to get to so in order to achieve
that goal I'm willing to go through the
pain and I will go through the pain and
I will take pride in the fact that I was
able to do that it's like mastery over
one's self
you know mastery over your instincts
that wants to be comfortable all the
time and doesn't want to go through that
but nothing that's really of value comes
without some kind of pain or some
sacrifice I don't think did you have a
formula for a handling pain I know you
said some things right now was pride
behind the bow zero formula for I'd
focus on the goal yeah focus on the goal
of the goal of that particular workout
of that exercise which is all a microt
of the macro which is at the end of the
year you're going to compete that's the
ultimate goal for
but breaking that down and so I would
have the goal in mind before I went to
the gym so I'll sit down and were to
analyze last week's workout so maybe I
am data analyzing in my primitive way
I've got my book there and I've written
down last week's workout so I did eight
reps last week with this weight I got to
do nine this week I got to put five
pounds on the bar or you know I got this
so I've got a definite goal when I go in
the gym that I've got to do and I've got
a portion I got to get through I'm gonna
get to that and if I gotta go through
pain to get there so be it I'll go
through the pain does that mindset bleed
into every aspect of your life or was it
mainly one-dimensional anything physical
I'll fall into that zone even now if I
do it you know guy I'm riding my bike in
the mountains in Spain but I still catch
myself time and myself and seeing if it
was better last week to voice is like
when it's getting really difficult now
before I just had one voice now I got to
I got the one which I made a video one
time put on my Instagram was like coming
up this [ __ ] mountain and I just got
off a plane I feel tired and it's really
tough and I got this one [ __ ] here on
my shoulder and the puss is telling me
listen man you [ __ ] did all this [ __ ]
before you 1/6 mr. Olympus and if you're
tired you don't need to go up that
mountain today you can go you can stop
man you can go back down and another one
got a [ __ ] lion here is no [ __ ] that
[ __ ] don't listen you've got to do it
man you started now you're kind of stuck
you've got to finish it you got to do it
so try to listen to the lion like 95% of
the time if I'm doing something that
requires that like if it's physical I'll
drop into that mode but if it's
something you know something else I'm
being social or whatever I can be very
relaxed a couple thoughts here before we
wrap up TRT
you know you're hearing a lot of people
right now I run a company and I got a
lot of friends we got all these agents
nationwide doctor recommended I should
get on TR TM 45 doctor recommend
actually considered them some T RT M 50
and then they're combined combining you
with some more you know some of the
other not in the service th but some
peptides have combined
this what are your thoughts on that with
trt I think if you are if you get a
blood test and your free testosterone is
below the the normal range then getting
TRT will be a super positive thing for
you and for your health I spoke to some
doctor in England who is quite
enlightened and if anyone's interested
as a book as well called the ageless man
mm-hmm ageless man II used to be only in
French but now they've published it in
English and it's a doctor over you know
decades has been treating patients so
basically like their age-related
diseases that we get as we get older
depression diabetes arthritis increased
body fat losing muscle mass all these
things can be reversed by just simply
putting a testosterone back we're in an
optimal range let's say so your health
and your quality of life will be much
better so I'm a big supporter of yeah if
you don't need it if your testosterone
is normal don't screw with it you don't
need it yeah but if you're below the
normal range you're going to be
healthier happier person if you put it
back in in the normal range that's for
sure
probably your wife is as well absolutely
highlight yeah my wife's younger than me
so you know you have to keep yeah yeah
and she's a professional competitor he's
an absolute that's just from Brazil and
she's from Brazil home yeah yeah you win
in every aspect without that you did
good with that one last last thing here
is some of the things you talk about
which is which is very interesting when
you start dropping comments on 911 and
what happened there and who did this and
who did dinner you're from you count oh
you're living in Spain right now what
are your thoughts about Boris Johnson
brexit how are you seeing that
well the brexit thing I'm in favor of
that right why
because I'm against globalization and
the centralization of power and that's
what they were trying to do to make
Europe into one super state like the
United States but it's not here you have
a common language a common culture in
Europe we have different languages
different cultures and also UK is an
island we're separated from the
continent so we feel like we're not
really European we're we're British so
for those reasons I was in favor of the
brexit when people voted to go out so
they [ __ ] voted to go out get it get
it fixed man
but there's forces and people that don't
want to do that and they're like maybe
we should have a second vote after we've
caused you a lot of fear and
inconvenience maybe you want to
reconsider your vote like almost it's
like that
so it may cause me some inconvenience
because I live in Spain it may not I'm
not really sure I don't think so because
I'm resident there anyway and there's an
agreement between UK and Spain that
Spanish people residing in the UK of
carrion and vice versa so I don't think
person that would affect me but for the
reason I'm against globalization so I'm
for brexit but what they're doing now
screwing around I really don't know I'm
not keeping track of it but people voted
to get out so let's get out you think
Boris Johnson is the right guy to help
make that happen I don't know man I'm
not big fan of politicians I think
they're all clowns and they're all
puppets they usually get in their
strings pulled from from somewhere else
all around now just go around everywhere
everywhere now and if they can't pull
your strings look what happened here in
Dallas now if you don't play the game
that's what can happen so yeah I'm not
big believer in like it's a game man I'm
happy you know happy with this guy
you're not happy with the the brown guy
wow I got a totally different guy now
yeah but what really changes is some
superficial things but deep levels I
don't know if it's going to change that
much hopefully it will hopefully it well
when you see Dallas you're talking about
1960 yeah okay
I'm a John F Kennedy this is what your
okay so I brought Jim Jenkins Jim
Jenkins I brought him as a guest and we
launched the interview on the day of the
anniversary of John F Kennedy getting
assassinated and Jim Jenkins was one of
the four guys who was in the autopsy
holding his brain however he got shot
and he says I looked at the brain
somebody worked on the brain before I
came to us somebody had done some work
to it so how is what kind of work
meaning somebody had done some incision
somebody had all the took some samples
of some yes way before we looked at it
and the brain was supposed to be the
body was supposed to be in a complete
different casket but they took it and
they brought it earlier where Jackie is
riding in the car thinking the body's in
the back and it's not it was in a
complete different car and his suspicion
was anyway this is another conspiracy
his suspicion was that you know maybe
lyndon b johnson was behind the whole
thing because he wasn't too happy about
the amount of attention john f kennedy
was getting so we took him that day and
he gave us a tour the whole spot like he
was explaining this run he hadn't been
there since years ago for him it was a
difficult time to get that we took his
wife that we had the whole video with
it's very interesting first week the
interview got you know nearly first
three days the day came out got 600,000
views and then all of a sudden the video
was taken down in a flat well that's uh
there's a sign right there yeah it was
interesting as I shut you up you're onto
something I was I was very curious what
happened with that interview but it got
some attention last one here before we
wrap up I'm gonna do speed round
I'll give you a name you tell me what's
the first thing that comes to your mind
okay very simple first one Mike Mansur
yeah Mike was a independent thinker a
rebel and big inspiration for me Joe
Weider
Joe Weider is a noun a businessman but
he also had almost like a childlike love
for bodybuilding interesting interesting
Arnold Arnold I don't know that well we
did clash in the magazine where he
criticized me and I responded to him and
interestingly enough after that Arnold
came to me at the Arnold you had the big
Expo there
so normally Arnold will go to the big
the big sponsors their sponsor the show
and do you know photo : their booth so
twice I was there with a little I had a
little booth and we were you know
promoting the nutrition of stuff and
Arnold came over two times to say hello
and shake hands and take pictures and
everything so maybe there's some regard
and respect there that because normally
nobody stands up to Arnold but I I just
believe and treat everybody is equal so
I don't care if you're president in the
United States or you're the guy that
cleans the toilets I treat everybody the
same so I don't kiss anybody's ass or I
don't look down on anybody I treat
everybody the same so that's my policy
so yeah Arnold is like let's be straight
without Arnold that probably wouldn't be
the body bowling that there is now so
some aspects of Arnold maybe I don't
like but that that is a fact Arnold has
promoted bodybuilding more than any
other individual
pumping iron through the movies and
through his visibility and so on so
interesting how somebody natural
somebody I'm curious yeah and I saw some
battle II never really got on that well
with him really no I never did I found
him to be what's the word I mean when we
say two-faced your face is kind of guy
that would be smiling in your face and
stab you in the back I'm sorry to talk
bad about somebody that that's passed on
ins not here but that's just how I find
the guy and probably the guy that came
closest to beating me also in 1997 I was
definitely not at my best I had the
tricep injury going into that contest
and NASA was very good so it was a very
close contest
some people think she should have won it
didn't happen I won but was definitely
the closest one of all my competitions
was there anything that happened that
caused you to think this is some way
about him or no observations or purely
observations but nothing that happened
no just I observe them even observed
people have they treat other people fair
enough because if you have some status
everybody treats you nice and
everyone treats me nice because I'm
Dorian I'm mr. Olympia but how do you
treat the guy that's the waiter or how
did you treat this guy that you say is
your friend and you know I kind of
observed people
Kevin LeBron Kevin is one of my rivals
from the 90s and one of the guys that I
get on very well with interesting
interesting guy very very talented could
have been better than it was because
many years he took like six months off
and played in a rock band and didn't
even lift the weight and lost like 40 50
pounds then I put it back all on again
so if you didn't do that he potentially
could have been better but he chose to
do what he did
Tom plants Tom flats was like is an icon
and I love Tom plants for his passion
his passion for the sport his passion
for training is like I would rather die
then not give 100% in the gym I mean
he's even probably maybe more intense
than I am
and you know he was very popular in
England he spent a lot of time in
England coming over there and doing
guest posing and seminars so he was a
big inspiration and a big personality as
well he'd never won a mr. Olympia but he
made his mark by being himself and
having this best legs we're never seen
legs like that before afterwards Lee
liberado leader Barada not somebody that
I really jive with you know I don't know
why I think is a bit I think we used to
be an engineer or something I find a
little bit a little bit cold and just
know not a big deal like no friction
nothing but I just didn't really get on
with him that much wisdom Churchill
Winston Churchill well yeah I think if
if facts were known he wouldn't be the
hero that is portrayed to be you know
they say the winners write history and I
think that's definitely the case there
there's a badass murderer [ __ ]
man that's what he was is that good or
bad
that thing's pretty bad
I'm you know I hate war I hate violence
I hate oppression and Winston Churchill
was involved in some bad [ __ ] so even
though he was held up for to be the hero
of the British people because it was a
was a prime minister and he made these
oppressive speeches and this Bulldog
spirit never give up and everything like
that so maybe being British people
expect me to put him on a pedestal but
if you see what I was involved with and
things around the world then it's not a
hero of mine
how about Chamberlain I really don't
know too much about him you got it I
know he was a as a Prime Minister before
the war and he went to speak without elf
Hitler and so on and that's all mine I
don't know too much about him lou
ferrigno lou ferrigno is somebody I got
on quite well with I think also because
he was married so you know me and my
wife we actually been to his house and
he showed me his gym there that he used
to train people in and told me the story
about Michael Jackson is to come there
I'm not quite what Michael Jackson was
doing that weight training but
apparently was at some point used to
come at four or five in the morning his
Lamone trained him in the gym there so I
got on well with the with Lou Ferrigno
as I say it was a family man so we spent
a bit of time together and of course he
transcended bodybuilding as well going
into you know Pollock doing the whole
kind of Hollywood and so on so that
again brings some more visibility to the
sport I think so he did a good job there
what was your experience with Mike Tyson
something happen with you and Mike Tyson
I believe I've met Mike a couple of
times we've got a mutual friend a guy
from from UK called Joe Egan and Joe is
Irish and apparently I used to spar with
Tyson and they became very good friends
and Tyson could never put him on the
floor he never went on the floor and
Mike Tyson said you're the toughest
white guy in a world yeah so I think Joe
got a book out now like the toughest
wife in a world so with you know a
mutual friend and then I met Tyson in
Vegas and hello Mike you know Doria no
no Joe and everything it's like he looks
at me like Dorian Dorian her
Dorian who said I'm Dorian Yates he's
like man
you're a badass [ __ ] that's like okay
whatever you say and actually I was we
were planning to do a podcast together
last week in LA but we couldn't get the
the schedule he's got apotheosis yeah
he's got a podcast called hotboxing
where you basically chat and smoke weed
which will be like lovely to do that
with my tyson so we're going to do that
next time I'm in LA and of course Mike
is there now in a cannabis business so
we have that in common as well I'd love
to sit down and speak to him I think
it'd be fascinating I think it's gonna
be fascinating for the viewer just just
for you yeah to watch you see how that's
gonna take place with the two of you
Dorian
final thoughts here I know you were
talking about your a nutrition company
is the website obviously we'll put all
the information yeah bottom there and I
know it's not yet for us but everywhere
outside of us people yeah order
do you wanna strain calm and we do have
the most of our requests demand is
coming from the US so we've done very
well in Europe and the Middle East and
now we're already put in plans in place
to to manufacture in the US and sell in
the US so maybe more hair again next
year I think yeah well we'll put the
link for anybody that wants to find out
about what you're doing there and again
it for me to go from us meeting twenty
years ago to now stating that having a
conversation together it's really really
interesting to me but I appreciate you
flying out and coming to visit thanks I
really enjoyed it
it's been great express thank you so if
you enjoyed this interview with Dorian
Yates which for me was fascinating I got
two other videos I want you to watch one
is my last sit-down with Phil Heath
seven times strolling here this is very
interesting on the things we talk about
with competition and the other video I
want you to watch is ten reasons why
those who exercise make more money and
once you watch these two videos please
make sure to subscribe as well take
everybody bye-bye
you